(Music)
Sun shining up above
down here it's 10 below
I'm moving on to a place now
where the streets are paved with gold
There'll be two trains running --
running side by side
Some trains are going out
Two trains running --
running side by side
I'm going to catch that fast express train
to my reward in the sky
Many rooms in my father's house now --
Oh Lord there's one for you and me
Oh there's one for you and me
No blues and no trouble
Oh my Lord sweet Jesus victory
There's one glory from the moon --
Lord another, oh another from the sun
Oh one glory from the moon
and another from the sun
Behind I'll leave this earthly body
when my Lord king Jesus comes
Thank you very much.
(Applause)